let's cut Mount Everest in half it is
nearly 9 000 meters tall but the Earth
is 12.7 million meters wide so the Earth
is really smooth but not as smooth as a
billiard ball in this video I showed
that if you were a giant who could hold
the entire Earth in your hands it would
feel about as smooth as the top of a
pancake that's still pretty smooth but
here's something else the name Everest
comes from this man who did not
pronounce his name Everest his name was
George Everest but that doesn't mean
that he would want us to call the
mountain Mount Everest oh no he never
wanted the mountain to have his name at
all because it already had an
established local name chumulongma he
didn't Discover it and in his entire
life he never even saw it